>> Laura: HUGE NEWS TENET FROM
THE HOUSE UNTIL COMMITTEE, WHICH
IT'S A BOMBSHELL, FISA MEMO.
ALLEGING SERIOUS SURVEILLANCE
ABUSE BY TOP OFFICIALS AT DOJ
AND THE FBI.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS FIVE DAYS TO
DECIDE WHETHER HE HAS ANY
ADAM SCHIFF, THE TOP RANKING
DEMOCRAT ON THE COMMITTEE IS
POLITICAL INTERESTS ABOVE THE
TONIGHT THAT THE INTEL COMMITTEE
HAS OPENED AN INVESTIGATION INTO
THE DOJ AND THE FBI.
STEWART, A MEMBER OF THE INTEL
COMMITTEE FROM UTAH.
GREAT TO SEE YOU, WHEN CAN WE
EXPECT THIS MEMO TO BE RELEASED?
>> I WOULD LOVE IT RELEASE TO
MAKE.
>> Laura: IT'S IN YOUR POCKET,
I WANT THAT MEMO.
PULL IT OUT, LET'S GO.
>> HOPEFULLY SOON.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO SEE IT.
I HOPE HE DOESN'T.
NORTH CAROLINA, SAID EARLIER
TODAY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IF YOUR AUDIENCE OR IF
SOMEBODY IS BELIEVING THAT THIS
IS THE END ALL SMOKING GUN, IT
ISN'T.
DOES IT NAME NAMES?
DOES IT PREVENT SOME VERY
INTRIGUING FACTS THAT MAKES YOU
ASK EVEN MORE QUESTIONS TO MIKE
TO MAKE THE CASE THAT THIS IS
THE MOST SHOCKING DOCUMENT IN
THE HISTORY OF MANKIND, I
BELIEVE THAT'S A LITTLE
IN HYPERBOLE?
SOME PEOPLE HAVE AND WE HAVE
ACTUALLY CAUTIONED AGAINST THAT.
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE PROCESS.
I LISTEN TO MR. SCHIFF AND MY
HEAD JUST WANTS TO EXPLODE.
MY FATHER WAS AN AIR FORCE
PILOT.
TO ACCUSE US OF SAYING WE WOULD
ENDANGER NATIONAL SECURITY IS
JUST SILLINESS.
THIS MEMO DOESN'T DO THAT.
WHAT IT DOES DO IS ASK THESE
QUESTIONS, WAS THE FBI FAIR?
FOR THE ACCURATE?
WE'VE BEEN MAKING ACCUSATIONS,
SERIOUS ACCUSATIONS, THEY'VE
BEEN CALLED TRADERS, TREASONOUS.
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR NOW.
DID THE FBI MAKE THOSE KINDS OF
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST INNOCENT
PEOPLE WITH LAUGHABLE EVIDENCE?
THAT'S THE KIND OF THINK THIS
MEMO WILL ADDRESS.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN GATES
FROM FLORIDA HAS BEEN A FREQUENT
GUEST ON THE SHOW.
HOPES UP THAT THIS GUY'S GOING
TO GO AND END THIS PERSON WILL
LOSE HIS JOB AND MAYBE THIS ONE
WILL GO TO JAIL.
STORYTELLERS.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THAT, AS OUR
>> WE KIND OF GET, TRY TO GET
PEOPLE TO TEMPER THEIR LANGUAGE.
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR WHAT EVERYONE
IT'S NOT EMOTIONAL.
IT DOESN'T DRAW ANY CONCLUSIONS,
IT JUST LAYS OUT THE FACTS AND
LET YOU DRAW THE CONCLUSIONS.
>> Laura: NANCY PELOSI SPOKE
ABOUT AN HOUR AGO AND I KNOW YOU
HAVEN'T SEEN IT, SO THIS IS A
THAT ISN'T EVEN TRUE, AND THEY
ARE LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO
ABOUT IT?
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, AS I
THEY ARE DEADLY AFRAID OF THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
MEMO.
HE COULD HAVE, AND SAID --
>> WITH DUE RESPECT, YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Laura: SHE REALLY GAVE IT
TO CHRIS CUOMO.
AS SHE READ IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> Laura: I WANT TO KNOW.
>> WE HAD MEMBERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OVER THE
WEEKEND SAYING WAS RECKLESS TO
RELEASE THIS MEMO WHEN THEY HAD
NOT READ IT.
>> Laura: WHERE HIS SESSIONS
IN ALL OF THIS?
WHAT HAS HE SAID?
HE IS THE HEAD OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IN WHICH THE FBI
RESIDES.
IS HE JUST NOT GOING TO COMMENT
BECAUSE RUSSIA?
I RECUSE MYSELF TO ALL THINGS
RELATED TO RUSSIA, WHICH I STILL
DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> I THINK IS ONE OF THE MOST
DECENT, HONORABLE MEN.
>> I WOULD SAY HE HAS RECUSED
HIMSELF FROM ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT --
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> I SAID IT WAS YOU HAD NOT
DONE THAT BECAUSE YOU HAVE I
THINK YOU HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
STEP ASIDE AND LET THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE LED BY SOMEONE
WHO WILL NOT STEP ASIDE.
>> Laura: YOU ARE SAYING
SESSIONS CAN'T LEAVE THIS
DEPARTMENT?
>> I'VE SET IT IN THE PAST, IT'S
PEOPLE WHO ARE AGREEING WITH YOU
OTHER THAN THE FEW WITH QUOTA
>> Laura: I LOVE JEFF
SESSIONS.
FOR SOME REASON, I'M CONCERNED
FRANKLY, THE MARIJUANA
ENFORCEMENT, WHICH I THINK IS
GOOD TO GIVE DISCRETION TO THE
FIELD OFFICERS.
THIS INVESTIGATION, I'M SORRY,
HE WENT OVER TO THE HILL AND IS
OF CONFIDENCE.
>> THESE ACCUSATIONS IN HIS
TESTIMONY, THAT'S JUST NUTS.
HE WAS ANSWERING THE QUESTION AS
HE UNDERSTOOD IT.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THIS CITY SHE
WAS GOOD PEOPLE SOMETIMES.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHY YOU CAN'T
BE RECUSING YOURSELF AND NAMING